[Music]
i'm mark bustos and i'm going to go over
five tips on using the blow dryer
tip number one is not to hold the blow
dryer too close to the hair
you want to hold the blow dryer about
six to eight inches away from the
hairline drying
one reason for that is you don't want to
burn your own head and two you don't
want to burn the hair
very simple tip number two on using the
blow dryer is
not keeping the heat on the hair for too
long once the hair has been completely
dried you're pretty much done
because if you leave the heat on the
hair for too long again you're going to
burn the hair and you're going to dry it
out
so once it's completely dry that's it
pull away
tip number three on using a blow dryer
use the pressure of the blow dryer to
push the hair in the direction you want
to wear it a lot of times the big
mistake i see people doing with the blow
dryer
probably just go like this
you can already see the frizziness
starting to take place and do the hair
so if you want to wear your hair over to
the right and smooth it out to the right
put the concentrator on and direct the
pressure of the air
in the direction you want to wear the
hair and if you don't have a brush you
can totally just use your fingers and
kind of give it a little bit of a tug
so tip number four is using the blow
dryer to increase or decrease volume
you can use the blow dryer to do either
one so if i wanted to be a slightly
flatter into the back area over here
and a little bit higher and through here
all i'm really going to do is use the
pressure of the blow dryer to push the
hair down
and as i work to the front i'm going to
lift the hair
up and out of the root to increase some
volume see the profile
you can see that all this hair has been
pressed down and this hair up here has
been
volumized tip number five is knowing the
hot and cold settings on the blow dryer
just like your skin and when you're hot
and you're cold
your pores open and close if you look at
an individual hair under a microscope
the outer coating of the hair called the
cuticle will look like shingles on a
roof
so once you put the hot air on the
cuticle or shingles it'll open up the
cubicle
and you'll be able to manipulate the
hair and move it into whatever direction
you want to wear it and once you've
gotten the hair completely dry
you hit it with the cold air and it'll
shut the cuticle of the hair and
kind of seal it and keep it in place the
cold air will also shut the cuticle
which in turn will make your hair nice
and shiny and healthy
now that we've blown it into place you
can really just use a minimal amount of
product to keep it in place